Now let's look at another whole concept.
And that is the use of a CMOS sensor.
CMOS stands for Complimentary Metal Oxide Semiconductor.
again, has a lot of things that it has learned from CCD.
But a CMOS, of course, is a little cheaper.
And it's something which actually you will be, you're using all the time
because most of the cameras, the small cameras that you see and in fact,
in the high end cameras, now all move to using CMOS sensors as opposed to CCDs.
Here are a few interesting differences between CCDs verses CMOS sensors.
One thing to note is,
of course, as we talked about before, there are these Bayer patterns.
But ben, beneath the Bayer patterns are these photo diodes.
We can refer to all of them as basically photosites.
This is where, of course, information is captured and
converted into light intensities and colors.
So these regions are the photosites for either one of them.
Basically, any one of these regions is a photosite.
And we want to be able to capture information from these photosites.
So the big difference is, the photosites in a CCD are passive and
actually do no work whatsoever.
As soon as something is captured, information is then moved over, and
there is an amplifier that's used to kind of take the exact values and
amplify it to a scale that can be measured by the storage device that comes in.
So I'm just showing an example of how things are copied over, one row at a time,
and then saved.
Photosites in CMOS actually have an amplifier right there.
And actually they can do local processing.
So the readout at each and
every one of them is local as opposed to in this case, not really global, but
actually it's done after all the things have been stored.
Here, every readout is done at the local sensor itself.
So in essence, there is a small local amplifier at each and
every one of the photosites.
So each and every point here, every photosite has its own amplifier.
So, of course, that allows them to do local processing.
One thing to note here is this is one of the traditional problems.
If you play around with the video on your hand held camera or
a cell phone camera, you see something called a rolling shutter artifact.
We'll actually, in one of the applications,
talk about how we can get a rolling shutter.
It's something which we've done a lot of research on.
But basically one of the reasons for rolling shutter is because of
the readout that's happening at each and every photosite,
if the camera is moving faster than the readout is, you will see some sort of
rolling artifacts, some non-rigidity in a scene, or some bending of the scene.
That is just because when this thing is read, by the time this is read,
the scene may have changed, and
that is an artifact that's common in, especially lower end CMOS sensors.
Higher end ones have a much faster readout rate and can do much better.